[Music]
my name is Barr I'm personally very
excited about this topic
for a number of reasons first of all
because it sort of applies to so many of
us but second because I've also kind of
find it fascinating how sort of both the
challenges and opportunities like the
greatest of those that we face
oftentimes don't always relate
specifically to our work per se but
rather to the people that we work with
how we communicate how we organize
ourselves how we think about the value
of our work and so I'm personally very
excited about this hi thank you for
joining
so yeah happy to share today some couple
of best practices and lessons learned
cool so just a little bit about myself
I started my career in the Israeli Air
Force actually as a commander of a data
analyst unit later on worked with data
throughout my career so at Bain &
Company worked with data science and
data analytics teams to help companies
make data-driven decisions later on at
gainsight which is a customer data
platform built a number of teams among
them the customer data and analytics
team and most recently co-founded a
company called Monte Carlo I data
analytics start-up were named after the
algorithm not the location in case you
were wondering
and yeah let's dive right into it so why
does this topic even matter actually so
I was actually planning to talk about a
different topic and I had a conversation
with Pete the conference organizer and
through the conversation it just
realized how some of these topics are so
important and so implica Bowl sometimes
we actually take them for granted let me
explain what I mean
so as I'm sure you guys like I've
noticed like awesome awesome kickoff to
the conference today and like data is
kind of like the like where everyone
wants to be right it's like the party
that everyone everyone wants a ticket
- it's like Burning Man five years ago
it's like the coolest thing ever
right however all of us being in the
data space we're sort of at the risk of
reinventing the wheel for a couple of
these things and in my experience sort
of working with lots of data teams
they're a couple of common pitfalls that
people typically end up finding
themselves one of them is a situation
that I'm sure you guys are familiar with
is where you sort of have like even
within the data team lots of different
groups like data engineering data
science data analytics and all these
folks like are not quite talking to each
other it's sort of talking to each other
but not quite understanding what each
team is doing and maybe like talking
over each other or not really quite
developing sort of empathy and
understanding of what folks are working
on I don't know if that's common if
anyone is sort of experienced that at
all seeing some heads nodding awesome
another sort of common pitfall that
happens is around actually like making
sure that the role of the data team is
understood hi folks welcome we're just
talking about common pitfalls for data
teams so the second one here is around
when the role of the data team is
misunderstood it's actually very easy to
work on things that are actually low
value I think that it's very easy to
underestimate what the data team works
on and it's partially because we're not
sure how to communicate around that so
I'll talk a little bit about that as
well the third pitfall is that
oftentimes data teams are on the
receiving end of lots of different
quests from different teams and
different functions in the organization
both internal and external which leads
to the team being very very reactive
like it's very common for data
professional to come in and sort of
manage the like the daily fire drill and
like figure out what you know what's
broken today or what needs the urgent
attention today and sort of distraction
from revenue-generating higher-order
priorities and then finally you know
this is sort of like the the silent
killer pitfall which is oftentimes when
data is broken or data has not trusted
in their organization sort of questions
actually the validity of
the data team itself and so that's
actually one of the bigger issues and
helping organizations become data-driven
so in order to avoid some of these
pitfalls or actually some lessons
learned that I'll talk through today and
I hope you guys leave today with just
one or two kind of practical things that
you guys can take back and maybe try out
in your company so three main lessons
learned one is around org structure
where should the team report to should
be centralized or decentralized you know
this existential question of like who
are we as data team and where should we
live the second around making an impact
I think there is sort of this
misconception that the data team is
actually a support function I think
that's that's flawed and it's in its
essence and I'll explain why and the
third is around actually making sure
that as an organization you can really
trust the data that you're using and how
to actually build a culture of trust in
your data
so diving into the first question this
is sort of a question that I see so
often come up like what should our
instructor look like where should we
live and for my experience there isn't a
silver bullet and there isn't sort of
one size fits all sort of obvious but I
do think there's patterns emerging and
there's common themes that we can talk
about and there's also some questions
and variables that you want to consider
as you're thinking about this and I'll
walk through a couple of those so this
is my effort of drawing a wave pardon me
for the semi wave that came out so you
know at the bottom here sort of a move
from centralized all the way to
decentralize and on the axis here of
time from left to right so let me tell
you sort of how I kind of experienced
this change and what I'm trying to
depict here is actually like just a very
natural change that data teams go
through as they evolve as both the data
teams involve and as a company evolves
so I don't know if this is familiar to
you guys but like when I in private
company when I joined in the early days
there was like this lone analyst the one
person who was like The Wizard of all
things data they sort of knew everything
about the data any question that you had
like what is this metric mean or like
why is it data from Salesforce not
coming up or what dashboard should I be
using like literally every single
question there was this one person in
the organization who knew the answer and
I was like personally terrified that a
person would leave I don't know if
anyone has like knows what I'm talking
or like knows about that person or maybe
you guys are that person actually in
fact for some of you and in that
situation like when there's this one
person there's definitely you know a lot
of dependence on the person and it's
very centralized obviously and as a
company sort of grows and like people
actually like noticed how amazing this
person was for us let's call her Julia
and in my case as an example Julia was
like The Wizard of all all things data
new at all and as the company grew more
and more functions actually wanted more
folks like her like this loan analyst
and then what ends up happening is that
every function actually hired their own
sort of data people in marketing there
were analysts and sales analyst and
customer success and product even
so we actually end up in this
decentralized scenario where like
everyone has like a data person and then
what ends up happening in that situation
what ended up happening to us was we
like there was this just like plethora
of metrics and very very hard to kind of
distill what was most important for the
business I've an example that I remember
was like we were trying to answer the
very simple question of how many
customers we have and like ask every
difference like single different
function you would get like 10 different
answers like marketing was counting it
differently from customer success
counting a different from sales I'm
cutting it definitely from product and
it's because like they were using only
active they were using churn these guys
were counting it as daily uses like all
over the place and it sort of seems
ridiculous right like how many customers
we have should be a pretty basic answer
a pretty basic question and actually
you'd be surprised so many companies
that I work with struggled ads for these
very basic questions because there are
so many differences in opinions and in
sources of truth and so kind of what
once we got to that point you realize
that we need sort of one source of truth
one centralized organization to sort of
align on the key business metrics malign
ants or the definition on the charter of
the of the organization and that's when
you know what ends up happening is sort
of having like a SWAT team of folks who
can kind of Shepherd the data
organization and and help help make
sense of the data that we do have and
then there's sort of a natural a curve
where after a while like other functions
like oh we actually need more people and
we need like sort of right-hand person
and you know like as an as a right-hand
person to the Sales Leader or to
marketing lid leader and so you actually
end up having a decentralized function
again and so these sort of cycles are
very natural see them very very often
and so if you guys are wondering like oh
like are we doing this right what should
be the right metric I just want to say
like it's very natural in common to see
this at some point later than a line I
think when you really want to kind of
get your [ __ ] together lots of teams end
up actually having both so having both a
centralized team with one person driving
kind of our one team driving the
strategy and also the dispersed analysts
or data scientists for each function
so definitely natural to have both now
sort of a natural extension to that is
like who should I hire right or like who
should be on our team
and so if you're kind of in a mature
state of your business or very early on
I think there's sort of three different
types of people that that you'll find on
data teams in the very very early day
you really want people who can run what
I mean by that is people who can
actually take data rally people around
sort of what the action means for this
data and run with it like if these folks
are not fast enough they're probably not
going to be very useful for the
organization so often times these people
are folks who have experience working
with under sort of quick timelines and
making sense of data even in ambiguous
situations often times this is like the
first or second hire on a data team and
focusing come from like non-traditional
backgrounds like management consulting
or finance or a bi and actually like
have the ability to sort of connect
people in the organization by making
sense of the data the second type is
around actually people who can count so
I'm sure you guys have heard this like I
speaking to a data science manager a
couple weeks ago he told me when he
first joined the company he spent like a
year working on these like fancy data
science projects and like setting up all
this like super sophisticated stuff and
after a year it was like okay none of
this is helpful to the business I really
just need to like start counting
counting customers counting sales
counting cause kind of spend and maybe
forecasting but really those are the
basics that you need to it you need to
start out with and only then you can
actually think about the Builder so
folks like build systems pipelines
architecture there's an asterisk there
just in case
data is actually core to your product in
which case you want to start that
earlier but really you know you first
need like a runner someone who can a
couple of folks who can count and then a
couple of folks who can build if those
are like the first ten hires or so so
we're still in the org structure
question bear with me
yeah I think was something that we've
seen recently sort of like kind of like
the this Big Bang of data teams right
what I mean by that is basically sort of
an expansion or explosion of many folks
in the profession but also in in data
teams in particular and this is sort of
how I see this expansion so started out
kind of an IT actually that's where data
belongs in the early days are where data
lived in the early days when data is
really kind of responsible for setting
up systems and architecture and like
making sure that the data is up and
running and most recently like data
actually lives in any number of these
functions right in marketing and Finance
you know really anything like I was
actually looking at earlier today I was
looking at my calendar trying to
estimate from the number of data teams
that I've met in the last month I met
over 30 data teams and I was like let me
see if there's any sort of pattern
matching or something it's a small
sample size but I just was curious and
it was literally like I could find an
example or more for each of these and so
I think it's pretty fascinating how like
there's this expansion of data teams
outside of IT but really in all in all
function so it's not that it's not only
that every company is becoming a data
company but every single organization
every single function is becoming a data
function and I think what we'll see in
convergence is that as the sort of the
rise of chief data officer is that in
the end like data teams actually will
report to a chief data officer according
to the CEO I do think that you know if a
company wants data to be a first-class
citizen the data team will report
directly to the CEO and we're seeing
more and more of that so I think after
this like explosion or expansion we're
gonna see it converge under sort of a
chief data officer to drive out Hollis
Stickley while still having sort of
decentralized data folks in different
functions actually another this is just
something I read yesterday actually in
the CIO magazine where CIOs are saying
that the chief data officer czar the
CIOs newest Ally so pretty cool that
sort of CSI like come you know full
circle back to CIO and CDO working side
by side so what can we actually do about
this as like data professionals how can
we help
kinda like Shepherd this or you know
what's our role in this these are a
couple of things that like I've
personally done have found very helpful
and I've seen lots of other data teams
do so one you know we actually a private
company that I was at we created
something that called the date of
championship club and you basically get
together once a month this was like all
kind of like data lovers in the company
and we would share success stories and
you know what we did that was helpful
you know stories where like we actually
implemented new initiatives based on
data it was really kind of creating this
community that I thought was very
helpful and enabled us to sort of have a
discussion about - about what's working
and what's not working well the second
around data literacy actually this is a
really physical story I spoke to this
chief data officer of an organization of
about 1,500 people who actually created
a rule dedicated entirely to data
literacy so they literally this person
was called head of data literacy and the
Charter of that person was to create was
to increase it illiteracy among the
commits in the company and they did in a
very interesting way they actually
created a scorecard for each function so
for every single person in every
function in the organization whether
it's data or outside so including sales
marketing etc they actually listed like
all of the people in the organization
and then the data skills you know all
the way from like so data-driven
decisions are Python etc whatnot and
then they like scorecard everyone like
red yellow green in terms of where they
are today and then they find goals for
their where they want to be I'm at the
end of the year
so you know obviously not everyone has
like a choir all those skill but like I
thought that was a pretty cool way of
like actually systemizing systematizing
data literacy in an organization and
then I'll just speak to the last one
here ask an act on feedback I think you
know data teams have an opportunity here
to actually solicit more feedback from
our counterparts in the organization so
you know once we actually ran a survey
pretty basic among an organization
asking like how happy are you what they
did a team how valuable do you think we
are what is going well but isn't going
well and we learned a ton of very
interesting things one of them was that
we actually weren't doing a good enough
job of communicating the value of what
we're doing and like people were unaware
of all these awesome things that a data
team was doing so the data team actually
ended up releasing this like biweekly
newsletter where every week we would
publish like here's like new things that
you can find data about or did you know
this and that about our customers or you
know kind of like fun facts about our
organization and that you know really
sort of helped bring awareness and
influence of the data so just to
summarize on this point you know I think
kind of let there are a couple of
different things to sort of think about
when you think about setting up a
structure that sets up your team for
success and really depends on the
maturity of the company maturity of your
data team and and where you want to go
with it in 2020 I guess ok so this is a
topic that's sort of near and dear to my
heart around sort of value and and our
oh I for me personally like if I wake up
in the morning and I'm not working on
like the five things that matter most
for the organization I'm very unhappy
you're very unmotivated and so really
kind of ask folks you know and on my
team or folks that I work with like if
you're not very clear on the things that
you're working on how they're really
tied to the business to the most
important things then you should either
ask or maybe you're working on the wrong
you know life is too short to to work on
things that are not impactful and I
think one of the questions that come up
in data in particular is whether data is
a support function or a growth function
and so I actually see lots of lots of
data teams or lots of folks kind of see
data as a support function and I think
it's one of the things that like most
underestimates our work actually data
team like when done well really really
is a growth function and can propel the
business forward and I think part of it
is because like we don't have a clear
way to talk about the value and we don't
have a clear way to talk about what
we're doing which is why which is why
I'd like to sort of propose kind of a
framework to think about the value very
curious after this talk if like folks
have any other examples of like value or
ROI frameworks for how they sort of
explain the business value of what what
we're doing on a data team I'll walk
through sort of this proposal but
honestly just really curious to have a
discussion about this after the talk
would would really welcome your guys is
a feedback and suggestions so just to
walk through kind of how I think about
this there's sort of two axis I'll walk
through the first axis here I think a
data team if you should have aligned the
outcomes of the work as it ties as
relates to the business outcome there's
sort of four main categories the first
one of which is for actually generating
new business so for example if you're
doing analysis I'm like which markets to
enter and like helping or sort of
figuring out what is the best sort of
international market to start with like
that's actually generating new business
and that is like real ROI that the data
team took part in another example or
sort of the second bucket here around
expanding existing customer so if you
are for example working on releasing a
new feature or if there's sort of a you
know if you're working with the product
team to figure out of everything that we
could do in the product roadmap which
feature would be most helpful that's
actually like pretty cool and that's
really does tie to
- real ROI for for the business then the
third back bucket here around you know
once you're working with with customers
actually figuring out like what is the
appropriate segmentation and how to
staff against that with internal team
members and so for example if you're
figuring out like which segments to
service in what way that actually
improves both the bottom line for your
company but also the customer experience
as well and then finally around using
data or so the date data team activities
to help improve the ROI of other
internal functions so I sort of
challenge you all for anything that
you've ever done in data if you know it
does it actually fit into one of these
buckets or is there a fifth one that I
missed I really do think that like every
single activity that we do can map to
one of these now it doesn't mean that we
don't work with other teams so this is
kind of the various business functions
and so if you think about this as like
this two by two you could essentially
start plotting the activities and the
roadmap of the data team in each of
these buckets so for example you're
helping you know the marketing team
figure out how to best deploy budget for
a new campaign that would be here in the
fourth bucket for example and so I think
there's a to use cases for this one
backward looking evaluating everything
you've done or evaluating things that
you've worked on and actually being able
to communicate how the data team has
helped move the business with this and
second as you're evaluating new
initiatives for the next year for the
next quarter this can help sort of
figure out like okay are we working on
the right things and do these aligned
with the business priorities so for
example if a company is if as a company
you're really focused on bucket number
one I'm like generating a new business
that's you could argue that like the
large large part of the data team should
also go into that bucket as well and
that actually also brings value to the
team and makes it easier to sort of talk
about what the ROI of the team is so
this is sort of a kind of like a first
draft proposal for how to work through
this but when I think about my work in
my day to day it's very hopeful for me
to sink through like okay how does this
tie to business outcome and what is the
the function that I'm working with cool
so on the two the third one how to build
trust in the data so I'm tell you guys a
story of actually this is an example
that I've seen a couple of times now a
data team a pretty large company public
company was actually trying to evaluate
their efforts as a sort of a data team
and evaluate their impact both on
customers and on on teams internally and
so they actually sent out a survey both
to their customers and internally and
asked like a couple of basic questions
asked for NPS what are we doing well
what are we not doing well and the
results were they were okay there were
nice you know left something to be
desired a lot of sort of the feedback
that they got both anecdotally and in in
writing was that when the data was wrong
when like you know folks were sort of
looking at inaccuracies or mistakes or
like that report just came out you know
there was some issues with them but
actually often time led people to
question and and doubt the data team
itself and so you know I think this this
it kind of like made it higher and
priority for them to focus on and so
they actually like did this like project
to rethink accuracy and reliability of
data and sort of like drove a number of
different initiatives around that and
actually when they resent sort of the
survey and the questions around this it
came much back came back much higher and
like there was higher appreciation of
the data team and a higher understanding
how to data team drives impact and so I
think it's like it's kind of a crazy
thing you can do everything right you
can have the right structure or hire the
right people use the right technology
but if in the end like the output of the
tea
which is sort of the data doesn't come
out sort of trust it or reliable people
actually question the validity of the
data team itself like it's not
sufficient to do all of those actually
making sure that your data is trusted
it's sort of kind of like a silent
failure if you don't think about it and
it's kind of like the key to having
influence in an impact in the
organization so generalizing from that
she call this like the vicious loop of
unreliable data but basically instead of
following kind of you know this example
if you're gonna start at the top left
sort of what I see and I'm sure you guys
have seen this too someone is like we
got to get data-driven let's do it like
let's use more data get more data act on
it start collecting like more sources
tracking more data then suddenly
everyone wants to consume data right
everyone is like sign me up for that
dashboard I want to get it every week in
my email like get me those notifications
like lots of our consumers of data then
you have like many more dashboards and
with that comes a lot more complexity
right there's like way more dashboards
than like people in the data team or
maybe even people in the organization
and then questions starting to come up
right like hey like where did this
number come from not really quite sure
or like hey where's this dashboard like
what is this based on you know or like
what am I supposed to do with this or
like who's even responsible for this I'm
not even sure and then you sort of get
it to this point where people are like
wait can I even trust this data screw it
you know what can't use this data
whatever let's just like go with our
intuition let's just go with our gut
right and then it sort of repeats itself
and so it's sort of this a sort of point
look like I see lots of data teams kind
of spin themselves in and out of and
actually like thinking about how do you
untangle yourself can start can sort of
be interesting this is just a funny
cartoon that I saw sort of related to
this inverse correlation like the more
data you have the more kpa as you have
it's like inversely correlated with your
ability
like actually understand each KPI and or
make sure that it's trusted so like this
little one so how do we actually
untangle from this I think you know
there's sort of this like perception or
sort of this common thing that we try to
do which was like get a lot of eyes on
the data you know like okay like data
engineers would be like okay we'll just
like use data
I like the data scientists will make
sure that the numbers are okay it's okay
and the data scientists are like okay
the data analysts will like take a look
before someone uses this and then the
data analysts are like oh actually like
you know someone in the business will
take a look at this and they really know
like in the end of the number is right
or wrong this is this like familiar to
anyone at all
yes okay strong yes so then you know
there's like this good okay if we like
just have enough eyes on the data then
like we'll make sure that it's okay I'm
taking a step back like I think that was
maybe fine in the past went like when
you were a small industry or you know
when like it was okay that data was
wrong here and there maybe wasn't used
for like mission-critical decisions but
I do think that like today sort of
industry has grown the importance of
data has grown the role of the data team
has grown we kind of have to grow up
from that and the first step to in that
is like actually taking accountability
like the buck stops with us when it
comes to data accuracy and data trust we
have to take responsibility for that and
so actually like standing up and saying
hey we're the data team were accountable
for this is the very first step in my
opinion in the second actually around
how do we measure ourselves if we are
taking accountability so the first is
actually like seeing if we can and I
mentioned like and PS could be one
example here is how many here how many
folks here actually try to use like NPS
or some measurement in the organization
if any just a couple three folks nice so
yeah I think that's like very helpful to
figure out if you can collect both
quantitative and qualitative measure
sending out a survey can be very easy
we actually used to do it quarterly you
can do it by annually second is around
actually data downtime so data downtime
define it as sort of the periods of time
during which your data is inaccurate or
arañas or or wrong and if you don't
actually measure that it's very hard to
know whether you're sort of improving on
this so I would say kind of measuring
data downtime communicating it and
actually showing how as a company or as
a team you're actually improving on it
can really lead to increase trust and
then the second part of year-round
actually like including it as part of
your stack okay we should think about
this is in an automated way
testing monitoring staging all of that
should be sort of bread and butter and
part of overdoing and for the very
advanced I'm seeing some data teens or
some companies actually building an SRE
team but for data so site reliability
engineers but in the data space data
reliability engineers so not sure if
anyone in the audience has an SRE team
for data one person amazing very cool
yeah so I do think that this is like
where we're headed and more and more
teams will have function like this or
something like that we're still in the
early days but if you'd like to
experiment with something new this could
be an interesting rule these are just a
couple of ideas for where to get started
around data trust so think I'm running
out of time but just to summarize here
you know I think as I mentioned like
it's probably you know maybe the most
interesting time in my opinion to be in
the data space the data industry and the
cool thing is that it's really up to us
like everyone in this room and data
professionals to figure these two things
out right to define sort of a structure
that sets us up for success to align or
work with the business value and to make
sure that the business is making
decisions based on trusted data so thank
you so much and I think I'll take
questions now
what do you think about data scientists
reporting to product management
organization yeah so I'll just repeat
the question but their assignment is
reporting a product that actually
happens quite often I see that happening
as well in my opinion what the reason
that typically happens is one of two
reasons either because data really is
core to the product and that's that you
know that makes a lot of sense for the
data science to report to that the
second instance where that happens is
when actually that organization is the
most data-driven organization the
product in particular and that's true
for any other function sometimes it's
the function that's most data-driven
will have data teams start out from and
later on spin out so that's something
that I see quite often and I think that
can happen that can work well when when
it's the right stage later on I think
when sort of data sort of becomes
company-wide mandate as I mentioned like
I do think it needs to report to sort of
a head of data or like chief data
officer reports the CEO or something
like that but in the sort of early
stages of kind of data being a part of
the product and forming the product
strategy it does make sense I think does
that answer your question
[Music]
okay so I'll just repeat that yeah
yeah makes sense so the question is what
are some of the pros and cons in a later
stage when the data reports into product
or engineer or something like that
yeah so I think you know if you think
about sort of again assuming sort of
this is a company that data is core to
the product that is like the shortest
cycle that you can have right so the
problem with like data not reporting the
product in that situation is that sort
of there's like multiple steps that the
data has to go through and so there
isn't the firsthand feedback which is so
important for like learning and actually
improving the product so I think the
like I see the strongest pro Pro is that
data is actually closest to what it's
impacting and there's sort of a direct
direct ability to also impact priorities
so if sort of you know the person or
kind of the product team knows how to
deploy the data resources in a way that
aligns set of product priorities that
makes a ton of sense right because what
might end happening is that the data
team is to our point about working on
very impactful thing if it's most
important to improve the product or to
you know use better data and the product
and the data team is doing something
completely different and not sort of up
to what the product team thinks is the
right priorities then there's a missing
missing link there so I think this the
biggest Pro is that product and data can
work hand-in-hand in that case I do
think that the con or a potential con is
that the data team will not be able to
sort of work with other functions on
done being data-driven and so that's
definitely a gap that you probably want
to fill in a different way whether it's
with a decentralized team or maybe a
different org structure but certainly
where the team lives impacts what the
team does so if the team works in
product most often they will work most
unproductive a work on marketing in
there if they live in marketing world
most often they will work on marketing
initiatives and so I think as one sort
of
kind potentially is that there are other
areas that require work with the data
team that the data team will not have
kind of the charter to work on also
focused on orgs that oscillating graph
is there a long term stabilization that
you've seen or is the industry too young
for that
it's a great question hard for me to see
the future so let me get back to you my
future self no I am I do think so for
for larger organizations I see both so
both the centralized organization like a
centralized data team with a chief data
officer as well as sort of data
champions in each function which serve
as right-hand person to that to that
function and in becoming data-driven
that's sort of what I see ultimately but
I don't I'll see you in in 10 years in
this conference thanks I was just hoping
that you could say more about how you
see esre
teams on integrating because I could see
like not having context being a
challenge for getting data quality rates
yeah great point so maybe generalizing
that question a little bit how do you
get folks responsible for reliant
reliability or ops or anything like that
when they're not actually part of the
team right is that sort of a question
it's a good one and actually if we
borrow some corollaries from other
organizations or other industries will
see similar challenges so if you think
about DevOps and engineering working
hand to hand SEC ups and engineering and
now like there's this whole movement of
data ops right in a similar way as we
see data ops hand to hand working with
data teams we're probably going to be
faced with similar challenges so I do
think you know it's it's a very good
question I don't think that there's like
a silver bullet or like a magic solution
similar to other functions we have to
figure out the processes and the tools
and the right people to do that work
it's obviously a very different skill
set I think who you hire for that role
is very different
also what are the solutions that they
use I will say it's still early days so
I don't see a ton of these but I think
those who have figured that out are able
to like dramatically improve sort of
their standard in the organization for
data and really treating data as a
first-class citizen so I think it's very
exciting to watch and see
[Music]